ok estamos en el problema número 15 y
tenemos algo así
tenemos la figura siguiente primero
tenemos un cuadrado un cuadrado parecido
a éste y después aquí al lado tengo un
triángulo tengo un triángulo algo más o
menos así y después estos dos lados se
unen ok de lujo y qué cosas me dan bueno
me dicen que este es el cuadrado
psd
se
este es el punto am y i'm vale 8
unidades
este es un ángulo de 60 grados ok y lo
que me preguntan es cuánto vale el área
el área de este cuadrado yo lo que
quiero saber es cuál es su área y bueno
para sacar su área y este es un cuadrado
con que saque uno de sus lados es más
que suficiente y para eso voy a utilizar
este triángulo de aquí ahora lo que
quiero que veas es que este es un típico
triángulo rectángulo el rectángulo
porque aquí tenemos un ángulo recto pero
además es el típico extremo del
rectángulo 60 grados 90 grados 30 grados
60 90 30 y cómo se son bueno porque si
éste es de 90 grados estos 60 grados y
éste tiene que ser forzosamente de 30
grados de 30 grados y ahora si tengo un
triángulo rectángulo 60 90 30 y esto
para qué bueno porque tú te puedes
acordar y si no te acuerdas puedes
regresar a la página de los consejos a
la página donde nos dicen qué datos
podemos utilizar en la página 838 838 me
dicen lo siguiente si yo tengo un
triángulo rectángulo de la forma 30 60
90 como este de aquí entonces a la
hipotenusa vale 2 x 2 x el lado que es
opuesto o el cateto que es opuesto al
ángulo de 30 grados vale x es decir que
x vale 8 ok y el lado que es adyacente
al ángulo de 30 grados vale x raíz de 3
x raíz de 3 ok eso está de lujo porque
ya puedo saber cuánto vale justo este
lado que quería este lado que quería
vale x raíz de 3 que es lo mismo que 8
raíz de 3 y esto utilizando lo que
sabemos de estos típicos triángulos
rectángulos 8 raíz de 3 y entonces a
este lado también vale 8 raíz de 3 y
este también vale 8 a veces de 3 y este
también yo lo que quiero saber es el
área del cuadrado y bsd y el área del
cuadrado en vez de lo voy a sacar como
a 8 veces la raíz de 3 x 8 veces la raíz
de 3 lado por lado utilizando la fórmula
que siempre no sabemos y esto es lo
mismo que 64 8 x 8 64 y aquí me quedaría
raíz de 3 elevado al cuadrado es decir
que esta raíz y este cuadrado se van a
ir y me va a quedar 64 por 3 y esto es
lo mismo que en 180 más 12 180 más 12
porque es 3 por 60 183 por 4 12 y esto
esto es lo mismo que 192 esto es lo
mismo que 192 que es la respuesta de
este problema el área de este cuadrado
es 192 y ya está de lujo problema número
15 ya está resuelto utilizando la
información que me daban en la página a
838 voy a quitar esto de aquí y vamos a
trabajar con el siguiente problema
estamos en el problema número 16 de lujo
en una mezcla de cacahuetes y nueces la
razón del peso de los cacahuetes a las
nueces es de 5 a 2 ok es lo podemos
escribir de la siguiente manera los
cacahuetes los cacahuetes entre las
nueces y voy a ocupar este color para
las nueces entre las nueces es igual a
una relación 5 a 2 es decir a 5 a 2 a 2
ok déjame cambiar de color a 2 ok
cuántos kilogramos de nueces tenemos que
poner a 4 kilogramos de mezclan para que
se conserve la proporción queremos
conservar esta proporción pero queremos
hacer una mezcla de 4 kilogramos ok para
ver esto de la siguiente manera qué te
parece si decimos que la cantidad de
cacahuetes que voy a utilizar más la
cantidad de nueces que voy a utilizar ok
en kilogramos cada uno de estos esto
debe de ser igual a 4 a 4 porque la
mezcla debe de pesar 4 kilogramos ok
ahora tengo una ecuación a esta también
es otra ecuación y qué te parece si aquí
necesitamos despejar las
por lo tanto vamos a despejar las nueces
utilizando esta ecuación de equipo y
para eso qué te parece si multiplico
todo por n de esta ecuación de aquí se
multiplicó todo por ende me va a quedar
que los cacahuetes o que los cacahuetes
es exactamente lo mismo que 5 sobre 25
medios ok de la cantidad de nueces y
esto esto que acabo de encontrar lo voy
a sustituir justo aquí en segunda
ecuación para encontrar el valor de los
cacahuates de hecho lo voy a sustituir
justo aquí y me va a quedar que 5 medios
la cantidad de nueces más las nueces
esto es igual a 4 kilogramos esto sale
porque los cacahuetes es exactamente lo
mismo que 5 medios de las nueces y aquí
puedo decir que hay cinco medios más uno
es siete medios siete medios la cantidad
de las nueces esto tiene que ser igual a
cuatro dado en kilogramos y ahora si
multiplicó a ambos lados por el
recíproco siete medios puedes recíproco
de siete medios que no es siete medios
es dos séptimos
voy a multiplicar todo por dos séptimos
de este lado y también de este lado lo
voy a multiplicar por dos séptimos
entonces voy a obtener que este y este
se va este y este se va y me queda que
la cantidad de nueces la cantidad de
nueces que yo quiero va a ser igual a 4
por 288 séptimos 8 séptimos de kilogramo
de kilogramos que por cierto esto es lo
mismo que un entero un séptimo de
kilogramo un kilogramo un séptimo de
lujo y esa es mi respuesta de este el
problema número 16 lo único que tenemos
que hacer es resolver un sistema de
ecuaciones y ya está el problema de unos
16 que lo voy a quitar justo de aquí y
ahora voy a trabajar con el problema
número 17
ok problemas 17 y tenemos
un lado canción o como esté aquí tengo a
mi hija ok por aquí tengo a mi eje x ok
vamos a poner este es el eje y este es
el eje x y tengo una recta parecida a
ésta pasa por el origen y sube hasta un
punto de chumberas uno de los puntos y
tengo por aquí otro segmento de recta
más o menos como éste o no espera
cambiamos la herramienta un segmento de
recta más o menos como éste ok entonces
me dicen que este es el punto am este es
el punto a este es el punto b y esta
recta pasa por este punto que es el
punto 8 383 esta recta se llama la recta
l
ok y me dice la recta m no se muestra
pero pasa por el origen pasa por aquí e
intercepta al segmento de recta ave
intercepta a este segmento en un punto
entre
cuál es uno de los posibles valores de
la pendiente de m ok tenemos otra recta
me gusta este color este color para mi
otra recta la cual sale el origen y va a
interceptar a esta recta ave por cierto
esta recta se llama m
ok tengo esta recta que se llama m y 20
aceptar a este segmento de la esta ave
en un punto que esté entre a ibm y lo
que me preguntan es cuál es uno de los
posibles valores de la pendiente de esta
recta en ok para eso date cuenta que
debe tener una pendiente menor a l debe
tener una pendiente menor a l porque
tiene menos inclinación que l
cuál es la pendiente de la recta l ok la
pendiente la
pendiente
pendiente pendiente de la recta l quien
es bueno pues sabemos por las fórmulas
que esto es exactamente lo mismo que el
cambio en yemen con respecto al cambio
en x y esto es lo mismo que pasa por el
origen este es el punto cero cero ok y
entonces tenemos el cambio el ya que es
3 - 0 entre el cambio en x que es 8
menos 0 lo cual pues es 3 octavos ok la
pendiente de esta recta y lees tres
octavos esta recta tiene como pendiente
tres octavos ahora por otra parte
tenemos otra recta llamada la recta m y
esta recta m deben tener una pendiente
menor a tres octavos y bueno debe ser
positiva la pendiente aquí lo voy a
poner la pendiente
de la recta m debe ser menor que tres
octavos para que se cumpla que que
intersecta el segmento de recta a b en
un punto que no sea a nivel en un punto
por aquí pero también debe de ser
positiva porque estamos en el primer
cuadrante no puede ser una recta que no
suba
y entonces a una pendiente que está
entre cero y tres octavos bueno pues hay
varios números lo podría tomar no sé
se me ocurre dos octavos dos octavos que
por cierto esto lo mismo que un cuarto o
me podría tomar un octavo o me podría
tomar no sé a uno sobre cien también es
una pendiente mal día es una pendiente
mucho más chica que tres octavos o me
podría tomar no sé uno sobre 16 lo que
esto lo que a ti se te ocurra todas
estas pendientes son pendientes válidas
porque lo único que estamos haciendo es
tomándonos rectas
que tengan una inclinación menor a esta
recta después de tomarme una recta muy
muy muy muy muy muy pegada le quede las
equis y ésta también se diría una recta
válida porque tiene una pendiente menor
y cruza fíjate que intersecta al
segmento de recta ave en un punto que no
sabe ni am a me podría tomarles por
ejemplo otra otra como por acá
cualquiera de todas estas rectas son
rectas válidas
entonces en tu espacio en blanco puedes
escribir cualquiera de estas pendientes
y dell lo único que había que recordar
era un poco la idea de pendiente y de
una pendiente menor que la recta el
problema número 17 vamos a resolver el
último problema por este vídeo el
problema número 18 que por cierto es el
último problema de este examen número 8
de esta sección número 2 el problema
número o déjame cambiar de herramienta
el problema número 18 y con esto acabó
esta sección y yo creo que me voy a
dormir problema número 18 y último dice
y me dan la siguiente tabla así que
vamos a ponerla por aquí
tengo una tabla cómo está ok tengo algo
más o menos así y aquí tengo el año el
año y aquí el número de estudiantes
tú
de antes de lujo tengo el año 92
95 y 96 ok aquí tengo x estudiantes
después tengo mil 552 mil
552 después tengo mil 238 mil 238
después tengo mil 457 mil
457 y por último tengo mil 351 mil 351
el problema dice lo siguiente a la tabla
siguiente muestra la cantidad de alumnos
que hay en la escuela weston entre 1992
y
1996 de lujo ok si la mediana de los
cinco años fue 1531 éste declinó este de
aquí fue mi mediana mediana ok lo que me
preguntan es ah y espera y ninguno de
los años tuvo la misma cantidad de
alumnos eso es importante
cuál es el máximo valor que puede tomar
x este de aquí es mi mediana
1.351 es decir que es el que está justo
en medio y vamos a ver a ordenar los
datos de mayor a menor aquí tengo
mayores que mil 351 tengo mil 552 de
sucede al último mil 552 y acá abajo
tengo a mil a
457 mil
457 y menores que él pues tengo mil 238
que lo voy a poner como por aquí mil 238
y para que éste sea la mediana para que
éste sea mi mediana tiene que estar
justo en medio por lo tanto x no puede
estar en esta parte porque no estaría
justo en medio mil 131 x tiene que estar
justo en esta parte por eso debe de ser
un número menor a 1531 así que por aquí
voy a poner a x y bueno x puede estar
tanto a antes que en 1238 como am
después que en 1238 puede estar aquí
joaquín y date cuenta que puede estar en
los dos lugares y se siguen cumpliendo
que es la mediana es mil 351 ahora
ninguno de los años tuvo la misma
cantidad de alumnos ok mientras no se
repita está bien cuál es el máximo valor
que puede tomar x bueno puede tomar el
valor de 1.237 pero
1.239 también es un valor válido para x
que sigue cumpliendo que este número sea
la mediana por lo tanto vamos a
acercarnos lo más posible a este valor
lo más cercano posible a este valor es a
1350 de tal manera que ninguno de los
años se repitan y además am sigue
cumpliendo que este valor es la mediana
aquí tengo 12 datos y aquí tengo 12
datos por lo tanto el máximo valor que
puede tomar x es
1350 que se siga cumpliendo que mil 351
sea su mediana por lo tanto x igual a
1350 es la respuesta de este problema y
ya está es el máximo valor que puede
tomar x para que haya dos valores acá
arriba y dos valores acá abajo
número 18 acabamos la sección número 2
estamos en el examen número 8 y me voy a
dormir buenas manchas